this is our Dawlish  dawlish is a town of 13,000 800 people  its picturesque seaside town set on the  south devon coast  it's accessible by road and rail  it's famous for its black swans and red  amber clips  it's a town that relies on tourism for  its local economy  but the locals are choosing to do their  shopping elsewhere the town center is  tired and in need of investment there's  a good mix of independent retailers but  at limited presence of national  retailers plus much of the trade in the  town is seasonal we need better shop  fronts we need to improve links from the  beach to the town  we need to create a family-friendly  evening economy we need a play area we  want a vibrant place to live work and to  play dawlish brilliantly British  you